[Music]  foreign  you open wounds for several things you  open wounds for healing or you open  wound wounds for further wounding and i  think this is opening of a wound for  further wounding rather than  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  we have to really understand why this  film is being deployed the way it is  in this current moment  it really suits the government of india  to have this kind of resolution this is  the end result that people at the end of  the show they should be inflamed enough  they should be agitated enough  to shout these slogans of genocide  recreating or doing genocide of muslims  in india  [Music]  when a country enters a cinema to get a  history lesson that becomes a problem  this is actually a movie that has been  made with artistic license with poetic  license  where the vantage and subjectiveness is  primary  [Music]  and i think this film is the completion  of demonization of kashmiri muslims and  that is very troubling